[Musique]
à quelques minutes du centre ville
vous pouvez prendre une gondole qui en
sept minutes vous élèves jusqu'à 2000
mètres d'altitude au nid d'aigle de
banque
une vue à couper le souffle vous attend
au sommet du mont sulfures avant on
venait dans les rocheuses pour ça
surtout maintenant on y vient aussi pour
la gastronomie 5e waouh c'est
spectaculaire comme présentation et si
on a une endive qui vient de bissy qui
est grillé et on a un fromage bleu
schmittlin du québec puis appuyez on est
le seul groupe the boeuf qui vient
d'alberta avec comme pure et chute
excellent et on a le barmaid hôtels et
on a une demi glace vin rouge et très
houleux mais les chefs du skal bistrot
et le québécois jonathan duguay
après une journée de ski est là alors
venez vous voir janata est ce que c'est
votre bureau ici oui je pourrais
l'appeler comme ça c'est mon but est
aussi que j'ai tous les jours pour
travailler
est-ce que déjà des employés qui disent
être en retard parce que moi qu'est la
gondole
ça arrive c'est tous des produits locaux
tout ce qu'on a sur le menu on essaie
que ce soit et canadiens soit bistrot
que ce soit pour qu'ils voient à
pré-en-pail une longue journée de ski
fait froid tu veux quelque chose qui va
avoir un peu de calories de neuf petits
plus passer au travers de la journée
pourquoi c'est important les chefs de
plus en plus veulent qu'on mange des
produits d'ici on e books une clientèle
internationale puisse choquer la norme
des très beaux produits qu'on on doit
montrer à tout le monde au monde entier
tout en bas au centre ville de banff un
village qui vit à 90% du tourisme
international l'année 2020 a été
éprouvante
c'était très difficile on a eu un taux
de un taux de chômage qui a grimpé
jusqu'à 90% à cause du à la pandémie
dont danse est une ville fantôme la
demande complètement
stéphane prévôt est co-propriétaire du
bloc royce trent une entraide
fantastique pour remettre sur pied
l'économie de banque
rue piétonne terrasse élargi tout a été
adapté pour répondre à une nouvelle
clientèle locale cette fois ci pour nous
les canadiens 2
de découvrir notre pays encore plus
qu'avant parce que c'est toujours un peu
un cliché en ce moment il faut il faut
découvrir notre pays c'est vrai mais
l'on n'a pas le choix il faut découvrir
puis c'est bien parce que ça évidemment
ça participe à la survie de tout le
monde
même le mythique château ferme en bam
springs a opté pour une gastronomie
régionale saumon fumé du pacifique sur
madeleine carpaccio d'elin même le
traditionnel salon t offre désormais le
meilleur 10 6 800 familles
[Musique]
en alberta la gastronomie passe aussi
par les spiritueux le alberta premium
casque ce trend a été élu meilleur
whisky au monde par la célèbre whisky
gbagbo pour l'année 2000 21
c'est un whisky qui est fait à 100% de
graines seigle et d'eau des rocheuses
on dit que c'est un whisky nous on
appelle souvent sont un rail pourquoi on
appelle ça raille un whisky en fait qui
s'appelle un rail c'est que c'est fait à
100% en bande de seigle tandis que
whisky régulier voyais faire avec des
d'autres sortes de grains vous savez là
votre colonne jean laborde et greg tout
dû à la qualité nos grains albertains et
de la qualité de l'eau ici à la perte or
sa techno si spiritueux peuvent se
mesurer contre des spiritueux mondiaux
[Musique]
et là si vous aviez un cocktail a
proposé ce serait qu'on nous propose est
sûrement notre signature qui s'appelle
howard clarks traduit comme corps se
valent jeter un twister une uchronie
donc c'est un autre jeune que vous
trouvez ici un petit peu de feeling et
puis du saint germain tunis a qu'un
petit pétard de
c'est beau et bon c'est vraiment tout
près à ce prix
[Musique]